we have some breaking news on the
shooting in North London near Houston
Station that happened earlier this
afternoon that we've been discussing
throughout the evening and this is a
statement coming from the Met police who
are seeking more people to come forward
and for more evidence but as part of the
statement and uh coming forward for
Witnesses we've learned that the
seven-year-old girl who was taken to
hospital is in a life-threatening
condition we've been reporting that
three women and a seven-year-old girl
have been taking to hospital the
seven-year-old girl sadly is in a
life-threatening condition we've also
learned that a second child a 12 year
old girl was also taken to hospital
albeit with minor leg injuries uh and
that that 12 year old girl has since
been discharged we have some more
details coming out of this statement of
this shooting that as I said happened at
about 1 30 p.m uh on the Phoenix Road in
North West
um London uh we've learned that police
were informed of this shooting that the
incident took place near a church where
a funeral was taking place and that it
does seem that shots were fired from a
moving vehicle which was then driven
away uh from the scene so it appears
this was a a drive-by shooting a
statement from superintendent Ed Wells
reads that any shooting instance is
unacceptable but to one including two
children uh is absolutely shocking they
say that superintendent edwell says our
thoughts are with all the victims but in
particular with the seven-year-old girl
who's in a life-threatening condition
and with her family an investigation is
already under well underway and I can
ensure the communities of Camden and
beyond that will do everything we
possibly can to identify and bring to
Justice those who are responsible and
that local residents can expect an
increased visible police presence and
again they do urge anyone to come
forward with information
whether that's to police or anonymously
to Crime Stoppers so the latest news
that the seven-year-old girl involved in
that shooting is sadly in a
life-threatening condition